so we have these massive extremes taking
place around the world and the simple
answer to why this is happening is
global warming obviously we know that
the Earth is warming up we have got
climate change taking place now it's not
something for the future it is happening
now and because we have a hotter Earth
it means it can hold more moisture in
the spring that we saw across Northern
India recently has been phenomenal I
mean huge amounts of rainfall heaviest
days of rainfall in New Delhi for around
40 years July rainfall in particular in
around 40 years as far as the U.S
there's a concerned this latest one that
we've just seen around that Northeastern
corner for example It's a combination of
things against those High sea
temperatures that sort of feeds the heat
off that east coast of the US the 20
hottest years on record have taken place
this century and we do know that when
you do get
higher temperatures when you do get
global warming as is as is happening it
is likely that you're going to see
heavier downpours you're also going to
get more prolonged droughts the extremes
are basically even more extreme because
of global warming we've just come off
the back of the warmest week on record
following on from the warmest June on
record and the melting of the ice around
Antarctica is at its worst on records
these are all
indicators that climate change is
happening now and this is where we are
going unless we try to turn it around I
mean this is like turning a juggernaut
around it's just it's not going to be a
quick a quick fix by any stretch of the
imagination but yeah the signs are that
it will get worse and so we need to we
need to make it stop but we also need to
cope with it when it does happen
foreign